we have a German living in Switzerland
sitting on the first row so let's start
on time hello everyone and welcome my
name is Amish and you some of you might
know my cp+ Chris site CPP Chris dog or
my blog sit with us on a Friday I'm also
on Twitter as Naughton and today I'm
going to talk about know and
specifically how and why to get rid of
no and the reason I want to do that is I
recently worked in a large ich C shop
code base where we just by convention
had banned now entirely from the code
base and that was really nice really
pleasant experience and then I had one
data point of something being
subjectively good and then this is
software development so then it's time
to start evangelizing and making talks
and convincing everyone to do the same
in C shop there are no general good
solution for non nullable types and in
c+ we of course have those so that gives
us certain advantages if we are trying
to do the same in C++ yeah I noticed a
few C+ experts arriving so this there's
nothing very fancy or anything going on
in this talk so if you want to have a
nap or something I'll wake you up after
after the talk the outline of the talk
is going to be first why are we using
now today and why I know is bad and what
can be done about it so pretty classic
setup I would say before we start let's
hear what the inventor of now has to say
about now unfortunately they didn't give
me any audio out so the text is up there
and if you listen carefully you might be
able to hear what he's saying
that led me to suggest a null pointer
was a possible value of every reference
variable and the possible mistake on
every rep every use of that reference
variable perhaps it was a billion dollar
mistake all right so that's Tony Hoare
he invented No yeah so Tony Hoare isn't
just some random dude he invented
quicksort he invented the logic he
got both the Turing award and the
phenomen medal and he was knighted so
he's a pretty clever guy but she did
invent no back in the 60s while working
on Algol W I'll go in some sort being a
predecessor to the purpose in some way
and he had a very good reason for doing
so which we will get back to and the
billion dollars is of course his
personal guesstimate
he seems fairly certain it's on that
order of magnitude but I think we can
all agree that from the 60s up until now
no bugs have probably cost society quite
a lot of money with all the crashes and
everything so given that both Tony Hoare
and myself are quite hostile towards no
I thought we should start with some
reasons why no is good so do you have
any favorite things about know what's
what's good about not okay yeah yeah
including the program yeah yeah okay
I'll cover some of my my reasons why I
know might be I might be good so we have
a function which might not succeed it's
a called get thing H we will try to get
you a thing it doesn't always find a
thing for you so as a part of normal
operation of the program sometimes you
find a thing sometimes you don't it's
not an exceptional case so we don't use
exceptions
so the typical old-school way of doing
this is you return a pointer because
then you can just return a null pointer
if you didn't find anything and I will
be using row pointers all over this talk
all the points apply for smart pointers
as well but with row pointers everything
fits on a slide and I don't get into
discussions about
should use this most poor smart pointer
instead of that one yes this is the
normal good all the way of doing it
you call get thing and then you check
did you get something or did you get a
null pointer so only proceed if you
actually got something the other way
around it's a way to also provide an
optional parameter so say you have a do
work function it takes a work item to
work on and then you can pass it a
logger if you want logging so the way
you indicated here is you pass a null
pointer if you don't want logging and if
you want logging you do a studio on the
second line here you call it with an
instance of the vulgar interface or
abstract base class so it's a it's one
way of doing optional parameters it can
also be useful for late initialization
of members or variables in general if
you can't initialize the variable when
you declare it and you want to still
initialize it but you don't have a value
yet you only default value for a pointer
ease of course then no so in our little
business logic here we're modeling
nuclear physics we have an atom which
points to its nucleus and you have the
nucleus which points to the atom and to
be able to initialize the atom you need
to have a nucleus to point to and to be
able to initialize a new close you need
to point to the atom right so how do you
initialize both of these drugs in the
constructor you can't really not fool
this so what you do of course is to
initialize the atom with a null pointer
for the nucleus then you create a new
Clues pointing to the atom and then you
revisit the atamans at the nucleus
pointer so we get a two-stage
initialization but you need a null
pointer until you have everything ready
and this type of cyclic references is
what motivated Tony how to invent know
when indeed so now can be good for
functions which might not succeed as we
saw with the gating function sometimes
it doesn't get your thing optional
parameter where you can just pass a null
pointer if you don't have a value or
fellate initialization of variables
so no it's good for indicating a missing
value so we've seen some good use cases
from now that's are typically found so
what why is now bad why don't I like No
yeah dereferencing a null pointer is
undefined behavior so if you if you have
a gifting function return to thing we
saw earlier if it's no and you try to
call something on it or you could try to
take a value or you dereference it in
some other way that's undefined behavior
and someone said seg fault that's what
you typically get on the system's I
usually work on I talk to Alfred this
morning and he reminded me that some of
you probably don't even get a segfault
now some of you can actually just use
the null pointer and that's just some
part of memory that you can actually use
yeah yeah but if you used to address
know some of you are probably many of
you are embedded developers maybe don't
have an OS that will actually give you
even a EBS egg fault so even even though
it wasn't undefined behavior maybe you
got a new pointer exception or something
it will still be a bug because it this
doesn't make any sense right so you then
end up checking for no this is exactly
like we saw on the first slide we try to
get the thing did we get anything or is
it a null pointer if you got something
we will do something and this is fine
this is intention this is the intention
of how this function is designed you are
supposed to check because it doesn't
always give you a value but when you
start checking pointers then since any
point you can be know that every point
you can then also how do you know which
ones to check so you get the thing check
if you got the thing you do something
with the thing the thing has a device
that you also want to do something with
but this is a pointer so you need to
check that as well and suddenly you can
end up checking for no all over the
codebase this will make the called less
readable and slower the presence of now
will lead to unclear API we saw the
getting function it might return your
thing or it might return a null pointer
and that's that that's fine that's part
of it
interface but you can't see that from
working at the code the same with the do
work function are you allowed not to
give it a logger or does it require up a
logger you can't see it from the
interface of the function the thing does
it always have a device or this is
sometimes not have a device you can't
see it from from the code so we have to
go check the documentation and hope that
it's well documented and when you
upgrade to the next version
let's hope they didn't change anyone so
if the get thing function always used to
return you something and now they've
changed the API so it doesn't always do
that or the logger didn't used to be
mandatory but in this version it is
mandatory your code won't break because
the interface changed but the code
doesn't reflect that it's actually has
changed so you'd better pay attention to
the change log or maybe even read some
some deficit they forgot to dimension
that
so we unclear api's I'll introduce some
classification of like our person we
classify both from bad to good or at
least from aren't really any good bugs
but from worse to better bugs which will
be useful the first classification is
where is the bug discovered is it
discovered in production you have
released your software the user is using
your software and you get a no point to
dereference and the rocket crashes or
whatever hopefully maybe it gets caught
by some manual process like a code
review or your manual tester is able to
to preciously your program will be
better if you had automatic tests like
unit test system tests would be really
cool if the compiler could catch your
your bugs so for now bugs at least for
me it's typically like something got
into a wind state that I never thought
about so maybe it's it's not found until
here at I'm not on the top here I could
write automatic tests for every pointer
in my system saying hey what happens if
this is no but that's going to be really
expensive the other other scale is when
is the bug discovered as
compared to when it actually happened so
it's instead bug discovered when the
effect of the bug is visible at effect
time or is it found at cost time when
the bug is actually cost so it's easier
with an example from nulls well for most
of us you discovered it at effect time
you discover it when you dereference the
null pointer but the bug happens
previously when someone brought that
null pointer that's probably the actual
bug but you don't discover that you have
a bug until they try to dereference it
at effect time and yeah if you if you
can just do whatever with a null pointer
in your program it's it's known as
normal basis like you appear somewhere
it's really bad
because you just something other other
things might happen and when you
discover bugs at effect time rather than
at cost time then your stack trace is
useless because the stack trace will
only tell you okay what were you trying
to do now it won't tell me what did you
do when the bug happens and the same
goes for your our reports from your
users because they will tell you I
clicked here and the program crashed but
that's not where the bug was the bug was
when they did something else previously
or maybe it wasn't even em doing it so
they will also be quite useless
so in summary and that's like we'll be
back otherwise no bad the referencing is
undefined behavior and even if it wasn't
it would still be bad you might end up
checking for now everywhere and api's
get unclear because you don't really
know there's one of the many examples we
saw and yeah finally no bugs manual I'm
at least can be caught very late in the
release process and at effect time when
the bug is visible and not at cost time
and it's cost
so literally a little interlude why is
static typing good I will assume that
many of you write sip of us from time to
time or see or some other statically
typed language so what are your
favorites properties of static typing
why why do you like it hmm compiler iris
yeah yeah
so an example again a function f taking
a person and I'm trying to pass a
company so this doesn't compile at least
in Norway it doesn't compile in the US I
think this compiles but the point is I
get I get the compiler to tell me
there's no possible way for me to
actually pass in something wrong unless
I intentionally do bad things and that
means I don't need to write any tests
where what happens if I pass something
else in a person and inside of F I don't
need to check whether I got that person
or not and also I can just look at this
signature of this function and I can
know quite a lot about what the function
expects and what it promises of course
this is a simple one but a signature
will tell you more when you have static
types so static typing is good because a
whole class of errors are caught at
compile time instead of at runtime
let's test so write less code to write
and it makes the code easier to
understand so what does null do - static
typing so normally you would say this
function requires you to pass it a
person you have to posit a person but
when you have a pointer that can be
known so what it's saying is you are you
have to give me a person or not if you
don't want you can just pass me no and
the same goes for a return type like I
promised to return you a person or maybe
I'll just return now so every time you
use a pointer you say you don't really
require that type anymore it could also
be no and I would say in some some some
sense it circumvents the type system or
the fact that something can be no no
leti of something kind of circumvents
the type system so we had our list of
why now is bad and yeah from the
discussion of static typing I think we
can add also that it's sort of
circumvents the type system so we've
seen that know is useful for many things
it also harmful in many ways so question
then is how do we go about creating this
beautiful new world with no notes
without losing the usefulness that we've
seen yeah we talked about Nolan ability
and possibly missing values we have been
a bit unclear about terminology so let's
think about requirements and
implementation details so there's a
requirement to be able to represent
values which can be missing and the
implementation detail is done the
techniques which support missing values
yeah so this is our requirements
possibly missing values this is our
implementation details how do we
represent those values so some values
which can be missing a person might or
might not have a phone number a print
function might take a color if you don't
give it a color you can just use the
previous one function might not be able
to find the thing you asked for so let's
call this maybe values values that might
or might not be there now that's the
requirement we have we need to be able
to represent maybe values and then we
have techniques which allow for missing
values so we saw pointers that's the old
way of doing that in c plus 17 we get up
a real maybe type proper maybe type
called to the optional and there are
other techniques to use like the null
object patterns or other other
techniques as I want focus on that today
so let's refer collectively to these as
may be techniques and then there may be
may be typing or no basic may be
techniques
and the most basic thing that I think
everyone is already doing today or at
least quite a lot is to realize that
maybe techniques are for maybe values if
you have a definite value you know it's
going to be there don't use a type which
allows it's not to be and this is
nothing new or fancy it's all cool stuff
which I think it has to be mentioned
NASA like the first step so I'll use
some examples now from like some example
code for the music industry since I love
music and we have a clothes designer the
designer can make a flyer for an artist
okay so we have to pass an artist
because if you don't give an artist
there's no way to make a fire because
there's nothing to make the fire for
it's not optional so how do you fix that
function art is a reference okay this is
very very simple with stuff I think we
all doing
it's very clear now that you have to
pass an artist you know when you read
the signature that you do it it's not
optional and it also clarifies ownership
there's no way that make four is going
to take ownership of this artist I mean
it's pretty clear from the name of the
function as well or from the context
that it wouldn't be true but for in many
other cases it's not always that simple
to see at once how about this example
you have an album and in our business
logic every album has to be made by one
artists so we have a pointer to the
artist that made the album would you
change anything about this
will you make the reference I would
probably make it our reference because
of the same arguments as before it it
communicates very clearly to anyone
constructing an album that you have to
give an artist it's not optional and you
don't risk no pointers you don't risk
anyone passing no and in client code if
I have an instance of album I don't need
to check whether there's an artist I can
just know that there's there's always
going to be an artist available for this
album and again ownership is clear I'm
just referring to this artist that
you're passing me in the constructor you
are responsible for the lifetime and for
the waiting mass that object but this
has some consequences I'm initializing
the artist member in the initializer
list and that's not only because it's
good practice often to do that but you
have to but because when you have a
reference you can't make it refer to
something else later so that's the only
place where you can initialize a
reference you can't initialize it in the
constructive body and you can't
reinitialize it off to the constructor
so that might be inconvenient in some
cases but what it does is it pushes you
towards image ability and fully
initialized objects so you have to
initialize everything at once and it
pushes you away from to stage in a
civilization and stuff like that
what if I want to add an assignment
operator to this class okay I can't do
that because I can't make the reference
refer to something else so I can't
really write an assignment operator but
in most cases I would say you don't want
to have an assignment operator and if
you don't have an assignment operator
you're not going to reuse your variable
it pushes you towards immutability again
which is good and so we think if you can
do without that then this is great and
it will often push you towards safer
style of coding I would say if you
really really need to be able to do any
of this then you can use a reference
wrapper to put around it but
I hope at least mostly you won't need
that
references isn't the only thing that can
replace pointers often you can replace a
pointer with just a normal good old
value so say we have to put a date on
the fire because you have to put which
data artists is going to play the date
class is probably just ticks since some
time or something it's if it's a small
and trivial class this is going to be
just as cheap as a point or a reference
so that was members and arguments to
functions what about return values we
saw them make fire function it returns
by value
so maybe the flyer is a quite big class
with lots of graphics and fancier things
so when I when I call make fire then you
would have to initialize the fire in
here and then you have to copy it out
into this one right but since we have
the return value optimization in simple
plus its sense that you're actually
allowed to skip that copy even if the
fire has a copy constructor with
side-effects all of that can be skipped
and that's a very rare type of
optimization where the optimizer is
allowed to actually change the
observable behavior of the program you
don't have to do the to run the copy
contractor but it's it's it's very handy
and you can usually rely on this
happening I wrote up so yes but that
isn't that only if you're returning a PR
value or another value in at least its
its ruins in some cases in C because
you're actually required to skip that
copy so what you just do is you just
take this memory that you're going to
copy into later and just use that memory
inside here and just fill that up in at
once and then you can skip the entire
thing so yeah I wrote a blog post back
in 2011
tried several compilers giving them some
tricky cases with like chain calls and
stuff and all the big ones were pretty
good at it and people have been
submitting their results since then and
yeah clang GCC and Microsoft are all
very good at the return value
optimization in my experience but tests
on your system if you really care about
it it's very easy to check you just make
a type that just does see out in the
copies constructor and then eject that
you get to see out or not
yeah so there's one case where you can't
return by value that's if you have a
polymorphic type so say the flyer is a
base class and you don't know which base
class will be actually returned you
can't if you have if you return by value
you only get the fire-type you slice
away the child part which is bad so you
have to use a reference or a pointer but
you can't return a reference to a
locally created variable because that
goes out to scope on the function exits
so in those cases you will often end up
with a pointer and probably a unique
pointer one final simple thing use the
standard library we want to show the
lyrics for a song so we pass it a Const
car pointer to the lyrics or since we're
super class programmers we it was a
reference to a string instead that has
many advantages the important thing for
this talk is that lyrics is never going
to be no you can just find an empty
string but it's not going to be no and
let's say we want to invite some artists
to our festival so we point to the
artists array and give it a number of
artists to invite or we use some sort of
container or maybe we posted some
iterators or span or arrange or whatever
but at least we don't post the pointer
that's the important part so maybe
techniques are for maybe I'll use use
references or values instead of pointers
return by value know about the return
value optimisation
and use the standard library over old C
style signatures because I really like
pointers so here's the classification
again what has although that's given us
on these scales all our old pointers
that now are references or values that
was possible bugs around here it's just
I'm not we wouldn't even call it a
compiler error it just it there is no
way of
compiling a program with no there so
it's not possible to represent in c plus
the buggy we're actually trying to write
and yeah so that's how to deal with May
with definite values you know we have a
definite value use a definite type don't
use them may be type or may be technique
for a definite value but not all values
are definite some values or may be
values they might not be there and then
let's see how to turn a definite value
into your maybe value in CB + 17 we go
to the optional real maybe type it's
sort of like a tuple of a bool and the
possible value so either it's it has
true and then the value you're looking
for or it has false or no value it's
very very very simple and then type in
attitude in that sense a few examples
say you have an optional artist and
either there is an artist there others
is no artist there so you can say if a
has value it was do you have an artist
or you can just use the blue operator
and just say if a and this looks exactly
like it did for pointers when you're
testing from no pointer now you're
checking if it has a value the big
difference is that now it's an optional
vibe it says right there optional you
know it's going to be optional that's
why you have to check it could be a
pointer for a whole host of other
reasons then for it to be able to be
optional so this is a lot clearer then
you can get at the value by calling dot
value and it will probably an exception
if there was no value
you can also just dereference it if
you're brave but now you're back into
undefined behavior if there was no value
and it has a handy arrow operator just
like pointers so both of these always
look also look exactly like for pointers
it's undefined behavior if there's no
value but is still very useful because
then you can check at the top of your
function and then I can just dereference
it for the rest of the function when you
know there's a value so we can get fast
executions we don't have to pay for the
check every time you access it right so
let's say we have an artist and we ask
the artist to go write a song so they
will go and try to come up with
something but it's it's really hard to
write a good song so maybe they don't
always come back with a good song so
instead of returning a pointer like we
saw earlier we can return an optional
song instead and why is this better than
pointers well it's someone bothered to
actually write the optional in here so
we know it's optional it's very clear
from the code it might also be good for
performance because the the value of an
optional is the memory is inside of the
optional memory so all the memory is
allocated in one place it's not like it
has the bool for saying do you have a
value and then it's pointing to the
value now the entire value is inside of
the optional so that means you get very
good locality which is good for cash and
you get fewer allocations you don't get
an extra allocation to like to get for
instance for a string where the actual
string is somewhere else on the heap and
the return value of my session still
applies so we don't actually have to
copy this out at all
back to the make fire function let's say
you don't always have to put a date on
the fire sometimes you just want to make
up a fire for the artist just for
advertisements now you want to make date
optional just wrap it instead optional
it's now you get an extra bull and maybe
you get some padding for alignment but
it's still a small and cheap trivial
class to copy which it should still be
quite performance so optional is great
for small value types what if you want
references for some reason so you have a
superstar class and our superstars
they're really big superstars very
expensive to copy or maybe you just want
reference semantics or some other reason
what do you do then well the obvious
thing of course you just pass an
optional reference but optional
references are not supported by optional
you can only have optional pointers or
values there's nothing technical
preventing us from implementing this
it's just that people haven't been able
to agree on what does an optional a
reference mean the semantics are unclear
I talked to the poor guy trying to have
to gather consensus for what it should
be and I don't think we'll get this for
simple was 20 he seemed sort of like sad
and about the whole situation yeah so
you can't have an optional reference
what do you do instead maybe just give
it a reference to the optional in some
cases this is actually a great if you
can always know that the color of this
function has the superstar already
inside of an optional then this is great
because you can just refer to that
optional with the superstar inside it if
I want to call this function and I just
have a superstar object and I won't a
need now to pass an optional superstar I
have to first create an optional
superstars I have to copy or move the
superstar into an optional which is
going to be very expensive especially if
I can't move it so this only applies if
you really know that the superstars they
are always inside the optional so anyway
so it's not a very very general good so
we
you can rap a reference wrapper around
the reference then the signature it
doesn't look as nice anymore but at
least it works it could just give up on
this stupid no more notes idea and just
send on a pointer instead because
pointers you can put in optionals but
that doesn't really make sense to pass
an optional pointer because even if you
have a pointer that pointer could be new
then you have to check did I get a value
and was that value not know and then I
can do something so maybe you just give
up and go back to the good ol pointer
depends a bit on the use case but I
think the optional reference wrapper is
pretty good yes yeah it makes it much
much more clear and I'll skip ahead a
little bit and say that this is kind of
you can't really compare to see sure
this is what we did in c-sharp and we
didn't yeah and that that did help a lot
because of that reason because it's
communicates very clear so I agree with
that no I'm not I'm on the fence about
that so what what does study optional
give us on this classification I would
say it doesn't give us anything but what
it does it makes the API a lot clearer
so we're a lot less likely to make the
error in first place and the error here
being of course using the optional value
without it actually having a value yeah
that's a good point it's it's it
increases the chance of this happening
but just the fact that it makes the API
about clearer it makes you less likely
to make the bug in the first place
more likely to that it will be
discovered if you forget so we cleaned
up a lot we got rid of a bunch of
potential notes by using references and
values our for definite time values from
maybe values we used stood optional and
we come quite a long way but there might
be some remaining pointers in our code
base okay maybe you need to point to
some physical address I need to return a
polymorphic type from somewhere you need
to allocate some stuff on the heap or
just you have many reasons for maybe I
have if some having some remaining
pointers that you couldn't replace with
the previous things we saw and some of
those pointers will be allowed to be
null at times and some are never
supposed to be null so either we can do
something with the maybe pointers the
pointers that might sometimes be no or
we can do something with the definite
pointers that are never supposed to be
known and yeah this is where I was going
to say basically what you come unto that
we only did on something with maybe
pointers in C sharp so we got no help
from the compiler or the runtime or
anything with our definite pointers
actually checking that or not no buts
but even even doing just that made the
code a lot easier to understand and
every time we saw one null in the
debugger is like hey something isn't set
up properly here you didn't need to
really know that part of the code to
know that something was wrong so which
one should we do for simple class so we
have to point to thing pointers and
maybe an a definite thing so there may
be thing might not always be there the
definite thing will always be there and
we want to call do something and both of
them so what about wrapping the optional
that the pointer in an optional that's
what we went to briefly into earlier
well first of all now you have to
dereference it twice first you have to
dereference it to get it out of the
optional and then you have to
dereference it to do something with it
so it gets a bit ugly but the worst
thing is that when you check if it has a
value
that value might still be no so you have
you will have to even check this in
addition to this
so maybe pointers they don't make that
much sense always instead we could
tackle the definite pointer we could
wrap it with not know which you have
some issues with yesterday however was
it this morning so user reference if you
can but if you for some reason have a
pointer you have to use you could wrap
it in not know from the garden support
library I'll get back to the details but
it just it's a cost it's a cross
template which ensures that this pointer
will never be known so now for the maybe
pointer we're back to the good old check
if it's there if it's there you do
something but this is what you want
because it's a maybe value so you're
supposed to do a check for it for the
definite pointer you can just call do
something because you know it can't be
no in the first place
so this wins us quite a lot actually
because then you only need to have this
no checks for the pointers which are
actually allowed to be null and you
don't need to have those checks in the
other places and it makes the API
clearer if you see a just a row pointer
you know it's maybe a pointer if you see
a not null pointer you know it's
definitely going to be there just l not
know it's just a normal class or costs
templates the constructor taking a null
pointer has been deleted so initializing
this with no is now a compile error
which is very very nice so what would
previously be a runtime error is
suddenly a compiler this doesn't only go
for the no prototype it's you can also
pass a zero and you will actually
compile it or it will tell you that hey
this isn't allowed but it's quite easy
to just pick another constructor right
so if you have an existing role null
pointer you can pass it in and now the
constructor won't or the compiler won't
help you but now you get an error when
you're trying to assign no to this
pattern
I'm trying to set it now I didn't get up
the error when you try to set it to know
rather than when you try to dereference
it later so he gets you get the error
when the bug actually happens and if you
have a good static analyzer that knows
about not know at least this trivial
case would probably be picked up by the
static analyzer so yeah I said in the
beginning I'm using row pointers
everything applies to smart pointers as
well not necessarily would not know you
can't use not know with unique pointers
at least not right now so it's not
always solution you can use so what does
this do for us
some of the cases that used to be up
here if you try to initialize it to know
in the source code directly it's a
compiler so we took all of these down
here and for the rest we took them from
here down to here because we now notice
when we try to set it to no rather than
when we try to the references or if you
if you are working on some Smith system
which doesn't give you a seg fault or a
page fault or whatever which may be it
up here and at least it brings you down
here so GSL not know helps you because
you only need to do no checks on your
maybe values less code to write the API
is clear and your definite pointers will
be either checked at compile time by
your static analyzer or at runtime
without you having to do anything else
than just mark it as not know in the
declaration so what can we do what's
what's the bright future what does it
look like we use references or values
over pointers we use stood optional for
optional values and DSL not know for
definite pointers then we get clearer
api's less code fewer tests we need to
write and actually many of our previous
bugs they won't even compile anymore
no more nose did we get there we didn't
we didn't really get all the way I think
it's not it like in in rust where they
just say there is no no right they don't
have no we still might have some nose
around but we got rid of a whole bunch
of them and we have some safeguards that
we can use for the remaining ones right
give me questions okay a linked list if
you need a linked list yeah yeah then
it's at least it's contained in a
library
so the standard libraries is fairly well
tested and used by lots of people so
it's at least safer than if you start
doing it yourself and if you if you need
to you to make any data structures like
that yourself I guess then you will
hopefully treat is treated as library :
test it yeah yeah all right at the same
time right yeah yeah I misunderstood
your question
no he wants and that's that might be a
common concern if you want to transfer
our like a raw object of something into
an optional that object you have to copy
or move it into the optional so that
might be a concern yeah no that's that's
a it's a kind of a performance trade-off
do you want it you want to have good
locality or do you want to be able to do
point to already existing stuff if it's
for internal use I guess it's making an
optional type it's very very simple
especially if you don't need to to her
allocate the memory for it in yourself
and it's just a duel on a pointer so
maybe you could like make her own and
yeah actually I had it on my slides for
over four times that kind of for fun I
had an optional of not null shared
pointer you can do that if you want so
if you have an optional not know of a
pointer then it's actually very very
clear I really like the semantics of
that because then you say the pointer
it's never supposed to be no but it's
optional if it's there or not then you
take the maybe Ness kind of away from
the pointer and into the optional so
it's like semantically it's very nice
but in practice I don't know I haven't
tried it oh yeah bit more cumbersome but
yeah you can you can have an optional
not no pointer I think we have seven
seconds left
time is out sorry yeah there's boost
optional which was the inspiration for
stood optional so you can use that but
if you if you can't use boost maybe your
your clients don't want to use boost or
if you really would like to use stead of
snow maybe you could just wait a year or
two until you can use it with 17 I was
talking to a guy from cute yesterday and
they have this problem all the time they
had to they had to make a string before
you got the proper Eastern string they
had to like make their own pipes for
everything and you can't really just
replace it because you have all of these
clients using so if you make your own
optional where if you use boost optional
it will kind of stuck with that it's
really simple we just in the constructor
you just if you just have a boom member
and a pointer and in just the
constructor we just reserve the memory
for the size of the object that you're
going to be optional and then you can
just copy it in there yeah I think
that's it so thanks for coming
[Applause]